oh say the rules
yes we're really white
so don't fuck your mother
we wasted our lives to this thing
me jams don't fucking socks
me
master we got your message about the
impending danger yeah something about a
great evil coming
I sense a terrible force that is
consuming our youth and threatening to
destroy the Ninja Turtles franchise that
is not radical I sense Megan Fox's April
Oh dick ugly CGI roadkill oh and all of
it being produced by Michael Bay oh
isn't that the man so insecure about
masculinity he can't transformers
testicles the same master what we do to
stop this bullshit first you must review
the movie well done that's not a unit
second you must find the thoughts of the
Ninja Turtles and remind the world of it
heart of the Ninja Turtles where do we
begin start with the basics try rescuing
April O'Neil what she's thinking it do
you see her right in front of you no
then she's been kidnapped go my sons
find the heart of the franchise and rip
this turtle to none
you